we are back
back in full force not necessarily
better than average
or not we're not rotating it out
i don't like fighting over the tears
anymore
okay
i just
is
generally speaking unless it's a really
hot legislation
you know she doesn't usually make me she
usually makes
um
you have to speak to the group
that's why i'm yeah
um
yeah yeah what's up
okay
i know that's bad you should have had
surgery your time had one
good morning good morning as we speak
we're on the floor
overturning the authorization for the
new of
use of military force that is 20 years
old
10 years after uh we withdrew
from iraq but not negating our ability
to protect
and defend our troops you may still be
there and the american people
if we come together now we are of course
happy with the supreme court decision on
the affordable care act
i think it's really important to note
this historic decision
once again the supreme court upheld the
constitutionality
of the affordable care act and the
transformational protections
that it provides every american no
matter where
uh where they get their coverage i want
to thank the grassroots across the
country
uh who worked tirelessly as advocates
for the america
for just the amer the affordable care
act
to pass it to save it
and now to once again save it
thanks to them and the democrats in the
congress the affordable care act endures
as a pillar of american health and
economic security
alongside medicare medicaid and social
security
when we passed it i said this is a
pillar of economic and health security
along with the others today's supreme
court decision is a landmark victory
uh for democrats work to defend
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions
every day we think how far will the
court go on pre-existing conditions
against republicans relentless at
assault
to dismantle pre-existing conditions
on one day on day one of our house
majority
democrats acted decisively to throw our
full
legal weight of the house of
representatives in the fight against
this
republican lawsuit we will never forget
how republican leaders embrace this
monstrous way to
rip away america's health care in the
middle
of a deadly pandemic more than one
million americans have signed up for the
affordable care act
since president biden extended the
enrollment period more than one
million americans because of the
extension but also because of the
expansion
of access to benefits that we have put
into their
rescue package i'm very proud of all of
that
and now democrats will continue our work
to build on this transformational
uh the rescue package to
make what's in there permanent in terms
of
in terms of affordability access and
quality health care for all americans
for the people we will continue to work
to lower health care
costs by lowering the cost of
prescription drugs
that is a very important part of where
we go from here
so we thank the court uh for its wisdom
and declaring
the uh cases against the affordable care
act who have
no standing uh we are so proud of our
president who's back from his bilateral
trip the trip to visit
to participate in the g
sevens hawks of course the nato talks
the eu talks and of course
the one-on-one with uh vladimir putin
uh he um i think
made a remarkable presentation for
america
to say america is back you've heard me
say many of you that in my
communication with members of parliament
leaders
in other countries uh that they were
very happy
to hear that america is back in full
strength as we talk about nato in full
values as we talk about who we are as a
country
and in true friendship to the countries
uh that had been part of our
multilateral
approach to to um security
growing our economies protecting the
planet
as well as honoring our values
uh it's um he was direct the president
about saying that
there would be consequences if putin
hurts our interest
including relating to russia's election
interference and cyber attacks
making clear that certain results on our
infrastructure our critical
infrastructure
will be met with a reaction earlier
today some of you were there maybe
i hope you were because we signed we had
the enrollment sign
signing for the june 18th becoming a
national holiday
ceremony it was pretty exciting to thank
sheila jackson lee the author current
author danny davis the original author
of the juneteenth legislation madam
chair of the caucus george baby and of
course
mr clyburn regailed us of stories of the
history
as well as any possible connection to
south carolina we can always count on
him for that
but it was it's pretty exciting and we
signed it sent
to the senate and the president of the
united states will sign it later today
it's almost record time from the senate
uh two days ago the house yesterday to
signature to the white house
it really is um it was a day of
celebration
also reflection i can talk more about it
if you wish but we have a lot to cover
here
at uh because because we have to get on
with the george floyd
justice and policing act we seem to be
making some progress there i'm very
proud of the work of karen bass
uh for what she has done
on that legislation and it's uh it's
challenging
we're proud of the bill that we passed
last year and this year
and hope that uh in the very near future
we will have uh come to agreement in a
bipartisan way
to pass this legislation all of it a
part of how we
built back better the
negotiations are going on about the
infrastructure bill
but we are committed to our full
american jobs
and families plan uh i want to just
commend the president again for
his leadership with our rescue pack
rescue package first
and now the recovery with the family
plan and jobs bills
but let's just review more than 300
million
vaccines have on people's arms an
average of 540 000 new jobs
new jobs each month the fastest rate of
growth in
modern us history annual economic growth
revised two points from last year up to
projected seven percent
would be the fastest economic expansion
in 40 years
and unemployment projected to go down a
full two percent
from projections of one year ago and the
biggest paychecks
across the board especially for low
income workers our work isn't finished
as chairman powell said we have more to
do
it would be premature to declare victory
so we know
that we need to do more we must build
back
better and that's what the discussion is
about where do we come to agreement on
what is infrastructure
how close can we come on the funding how
is it paid for
those are matters of discussion right
now
and we hope that we can have bipartisan
infrastructure bill
however that doesn't mean that we will
abandon
how we see infrastructure for the future
not 1959 with all due respect president
eisenhower and
the interstate highway system that was
important
but now we have to have other features
that relate to
to broadband to water systems that are
now over 100 years
old the list goes on but you can't build
back better
unless you have more people building
back better and that's why the human
infrastructure pieces us are so
important
child care let's get enable women to
fully participate
child care home health care issues like
that family and medical leave
the child tax credit issues like that
that enable
families to fully participate in the
economic prosperity of our country as we
go forward
at the same time their children and
their loved ones
safe so again um
we like to say build back better with
women
we must also address the economic
uh inequality so some of our members say
build back better with equity
and for that reason yesterday some of
you here when we
put forth the members of the select
committee on economic disparity
and fairness and growth as we provide it
proceed with the committee we we've got
to listen
attentively to those in most need listen
respectfully
to some new ideas about how we go
forward and do so was openness
listening to everyone concerned it is a
priority of addressing the wealth
and financial disparity it's broadened
across the board you've seen the
headlines some of them you've written
about how
this just persists and i won't read you
my dear colleague to my members that
quotes
many of these uh headlines i'm very
proud of our chair
the committee jim himes who brings
extensive professional experience as
well as
private in the private sector and
expertise in affordable housing is one
way to address the racial
racial uh inequality in inequity
uh of ownership marcy kapter focusing on
regional economic revitalization
representing the great lakes area
and areas of that have lost jobs in the
last
few decades when more leading action to
close the racial wealth
gap from her perspective as an inner
city representative
vicente gonzalez recognizing the ties
between
economic growth and infrastructure
connectivities there
in a rural area
affected by trade immediately with
mexico
with immigration and the rest a very
interesting perspective pramila jayapal
who has been
talking about make worker fairness
making workers
well she she has many good ideas that
will come before the committee but they
all relate to
delivering workers better wages and a
better future
angie craig representing family farmers
and ag community
and with a strong emphasis on
unionization uh alex andrea
ocasio-cortez addressing generational
disparities as well as increasing
worker power everybody's about
increasing more for power
and so is she and sarah jacobs focusing
on the future of work
with both a family and global
perspective
i take the time to say that because that
embraces
many of the challenges we face
all of it to set a higher standard for
how we
pass our legislation it's not a
legislative committee or make
recommendations
to the committees of the standing
committees of jurisdiction
and as we talk about such actions as we
talked about
juneteenth we talk with sadness
and pride about the passing legislation
to designate the national pulse memorial
that site a national memorial
we did that yesterday hearts break
thinking about that haven for young
people
pulse where yellen lgbtq mostly
americans enjoyed music and dancing
was violated by an act of bigotry
and violence when i met with the
survivors and families immediately after
that
and then later when they came to dc to
make their case it was
all about stop the gun violence
stop the gun violence we were there to
console them but they were using their
pain
uh to prevent other people from joining
that horrible club
uh of of losing a loved one
today again also marks six years since
the racist attack on
mother emanuel church in charleston this
all comes down to the gun violence issue
and as we keep saying we are not going
away until
we we pass legislation uh to stop
gun violence and we will have a better
chance to do it if we pass hr1
clearly the republicans in congress are
handmaidens
of the gun vi gun industry and they have
prevented us from
passing and although it's bipartisan
it's not
enough for us to pass it uh in the
senate so
again the for the people act is really
important for many reasons
including the personal safety of
america's families and children
and again a lot going on
pulse pulse and and
june 10th and stopping gun violence and
passing h.r
1 and we're making progress there as you
probably
are observing so it's a busy time i'm
proud of our members they have been
working on their
committee work who can talk more about
that what will be coming up
next week and the week after before or
the fourth of july
uh as we celebrate the birth of our
nation we want to do so
with having made progress for the people
yes sir
thank you madam speaker thank you
sponsored boxes i appreciate it um
speaking about some of these big issues
that you have over the next several days
i want to read something that my
colleague got from congress for the
yarmouth he said
i think our caucus understands that
essentially we're all joe manchin with
the margins we have everybody has the
ability
to take whatever we're trying to do we
have zero margin essentially everybody's
in a position to sabotage
whatever we're doing do you feel that
way no i feel that we are building
consensus
in a very positive way and congress will
work its will
in a way that is respectful uh we have
in our party
a common core and that is we are here
for america's working families and i
have no doubt
uh that we will have legislation to help
america's working families
your response that there are risks in
the democratic party there are bits
we're
a democratic party we're not a lockstep
rubber stamp who would want to be along
to a party like that
across the island do that but we are a
party of ideas and dynamism
and we respect differences of opinion
but at the end of the day we know we
will have unity
to promote the well-being of america's
working families
thank you madam speaker um the supreme
court this fall will review a
mississippi law that bans most abortions
after 15 weeks of pregnancy
is an unborn baby at 15 weeks of human
being
let me just say that i am a big
supporter of roe v
wade i'm a mother of five children in
six years i've
had some standing on this issue as to
respecting a woman's right to choose
is it a human being do you have any
on infrastructure and on the left and
some of the house who say that the
bipartisan package
has to include expansive bold climate
change
provisions in order for them to support
the bipartisan component
is that a position that you take or
would it be okay to include those
perhaps
in the reconciliation bill that's also
being formulated
well i don't think there's any question
that the more bipartisan abilities the
less green it is
because the republicans in addition to
being in the hand pocket of the fossil
fuel industry
in a gun industry are in the pocket of
the fossil fuel industry and that's one
of the reasons it's hard for us to get
uh as much as we want on
high speed rail and trent mass transit
and the rest because they
want people and cars on the road using
that
but there they will we will have
provisions for electrification
which some of the uh republicans have
not been enthusiastic about i'm not
worried about
what you proposed we we know
that we one bill is not going to do it
for us
we have to have a bill but not just
about addressing green
but addressing women uh people who are
in charge
people with disabilities who need i mean
care and the rest so that
their family members and they can fully
participate in how we go forward
i don't think that that's a problem i
think it's important for people to say
what their priorities are as we develop
the how we go forward one step two step
i don't think that's debate i think the
debate is where do we want to end up
and how will that happen and i'm very
confident
that we will have a bill that you cannot
build infrastructure
without resilience and sustainability
and protecting our planet you just can't
so whether it's in the actual bill or
otherwise
we could not be better served than the
chairman of our committee
peter defazio has been for 30 years or
maybe a little bit more
on the committee of transportation and
infrastructure he was a chairman of the
natural resources committed before that
uh nothing before that but i'm not
saying that hasn't been here that long
and um uh nobody knows better how to
make
transportation resilient how to
use different materials uh to be
protecting the planet
as we move people and and create jobs so
i think we're in a good place and uh i
wouldn't
i don't see a whole lot of value in
deciding whether it's one bill or two
bills
we're going to get the job done
uh uh several republicans have uh
allowed the lawsuit to try to knock down
the bonds to enforce the metal detectors
outside
the house chamber is their plan uh
as to when if ever
those will be removed or the idea that
they'll stay
no as long as there's a threat we'll
have to have protection
is is there any contagion do you have
that
do you said no okay do you um i wonder
if you have any reaction to the
bipartisan infrastructure plan
on the substance the pay fors have now
come out
i'm assuming you've talked to some of
your members that have been involved in
these discussions decidedly smaller
different papers than you would want i'm
curious if you have any reaction to that
well i don't i don't know that we've
seen all the implications
of the pay force i myself do not think
we should be
taking money out of the pockets of
people on unemployment
or take money out of the
rescue package because it's there for a
purpose
but let's just see what it is that the
administration i know will be
reviewing this i haven't frankly seen
all this you know it's it's very new and
it's not just
what is in the public domain but what's
in
the the devil frequently and the angels
are frequently in the detail so let's
just see
but uh i i think the first order of
business is what is this for
i've never been one to talk about
paperwork at the beginning of any
discussion
on infrastructure what do what does the
country need
uh what is in the bill to help meet
those needs
and then let's just see where we go from
there so i don't start with papers and
work but that's what they're starting so
you kind of you have it seems that you
have an issue with this process or
well i just for one thing that i i
thought i don't i'm not even sure if
it's in but the one thing they were
going to do was
expand the gas tax i would not be for
that i don't think that
american people america's working
families uh should be footing the bill
for roads and bridges and the rest that
america's wealthiest people
and their businesses are using without
paying
uh for them so i i i just
have not been before expanding against
it you have a gas tax
expanding it is a more of the issue
okay mr speaker a quick follow-up can
you expect
that maybe medicare to negotiate over
the cost of prescription drugs will be
included in the reconciliation package
i hope so uh we have
since 2005 2006
enabling the secretary to negotiate for
prescription drug
prices lower prescription drug has been
a a high part of our agenda
when we 1906.07 in the first
100 hours we passed our six for o6
the six most important bills including
raising the minimum wage
at that time it hadn't been increased in
11 years
all six of them became law except
enabling the secretary to negotiate for
that so we've been fighting for that for
a long time
whether it's part of one package or
another remains to be seen
but we will persist because when we did
the affordable care act we did so to
lower the cost
of health care for all americans and we
did
except in one area the cost of
prescription drugs
so this is something that we will
persist on and when we prevail
it will enable us to expand and benefits
in
in medicare to dental um visual
hearing and the rest and it's a
hundreds of billions of dollars that
will be saved so
this is a a core value for us where we
have
great support in our caucus and have had
uh what was that 05 now what are we over
15
over 15 years but there are centrist
democrats who have raised concerns about
that negotiation piece
in house one or two why
ten well i i think that that
at the end of the day the point is do
you want to vote to enable
the pharmaceutical companies to have
america's families subsidize lower cost
for prescription drugs in other
countries
uh where they're paying three four five
times
less than we are paying as we subsidize
the research and development for it so i
think that um
i i don't even see it being 10 maybe you
do
but i have i get a different response to
them on what they would vote for
as part of lowering the cost of
prescription drugs
in the united states and not subsidizing
the cost of prescription drugs
in other countries enhancing the profits
of the pharmaceutical companies to the
tune of a
half a trillion dollars or maybe more
and would they be opposed to using that
money
for better benefits for people on
medicare that's an eternal debate that
is one that
is uh one that we all welcome and the
special opinions now i come from an area
that has a lot of
of a pharmaceutical uh
industry research and the rest and you
have to be a patient investor to be an
investor
in a pharmaceutical company because it
takes a long time for discovery and
approval and the rest
but we don't want you spending the money
that you make on television ads
and passing that on to our constituents
thank you very much
that's right